you know sometimes there's this uh story  that's told if you don't think  one person can make a difference  think about how annoying one mosquito  can be when it gets into your house at  night and similarly there was this  planned parenthood anti-planned  parenthood protest with all these  anti-abortion people holding signs one  guy showed up with a sign that had an  arrow and it said these people are  losers he shut down the entire protest  it can make a difference  like that  no no no no the traffic the people  ruining the protest  no no no you guys do whatever you want  are you guys headed out yes it's  unfortunate that this  one sign can ruin a protest